after enduring a pandemic and months of
changing regulations
relief is on the menu for dozens of
restaurants in henderson
the city is offering up some economic
relief through a
million dollar grant for those who have
been impacted by cobit covid19
and applications opened just today
online joe mohler explains how this
latest move
could be the lifeline that restaurants
need
restaurants across the state have been
forced to cut their capacity to 25
percent now the owners of restaurants
including pacific diner here in the
water street district say it has been a
struggle
during the pandemic and now the city of
henderson wants to help we have
this whole front that we could do tables
out in front
yvonne and marvin wallace own pacific
diner so this space was almost double
what it is
now the 25 capacity restriction is
taking a toll on business
we're doing everything we can thinking
outside of the box
to make sure we can continue to make it
they say they will now apply for a new
grant that the city of henderson
announced
hopefully a hundred restaurants will
apply for this and 100 restaurants will
get the max that they need
the city is giving 10 thousand dollar
grants to 100 eligible restaurants for a
total of 1 million dollars
applications were accepted starting
tuesday city councilwoman michelle
romero says they want to help
those struggling to get by they have put
their heart and soul
into their businesses and you know they
have a lot of people relying on them
to for their employment the funds are
coming from cares act money
the grants must be used for copen 19
related modifications such as seating
changes or new reservation systems
these are new expenses owners are having
to think about we went down to
55 when we went 50 percent and then from
there
we went down to twenty seven people rami
maska owns me peru restaurant capacity
changes are hurting but so are new
expenses such as increasing food prices
and new supplies he says grand money
would help now this time we're
definitely going to be applying
as soon as possible applications are due
by december 4th and some people were
saying they were having issues with the
website where you do
apply a city spokesperson says they are
working to get that issue fixed and a
check back regularly
reporting in henderson joe mohler 8 news
now